Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Oxygen Not Included!
I know I said that I was going to stop for today, but I literally can't.
*laughs* I love this game so much and I'm finally onto something good here,
where I'm about to break through everything! I'm about to unleash my creativity
and make this actually work and I can't stop.
I haven't had this much fun, not just recording a game,
but playing a game in a long, long time.
I love this so much.
Ah man! And I know they're focused on other stuff besides getting what they need and they're
honestly surprisingly unstressed about all this. Especially considering they gotta go down here and breathe in the uh
the, the contaminated oxygen.
And we've got a little bit of overflow over there but,
we'll get through that soon enough.
Eventually, anyways.
So he's gotta get all the way down there... At least they have plenty of oxygen to breathe, I suppose. So that is a thing that does exist.
But, once that's done, we'll have some extra water. We'll actually be creating water. Y'know... not 'creating water.'
We'll be adding more water to our water supply...
Uh, and then we'll be able to say that we did all we could do and our amazing people.
Sha boop! And just like that. I forgot about those, but that's okay because we don't need to worry about that.
Bada bing bada boom. Oops, can we get a higher priority on that. Shaboody boop boop, okay.
So now that that's done...
Ooh shit, that's unreachable. Okay, so we actually gotta destroy that. Aw shit, and then cancel that.
Okay, well that's fine. Cause then they'll be able to do that just - yeah, yeah, okay. That, that makes more sense.
I was dumb about that... But thankfully they put up the other wall first.
But we got a new arrival! Who we got? *reads* 'Can't dig it,' don't like that.
Uh, scaredy cat, can't fight, uncultured...
Alright Ellie, okay Ellie, I remember an Ellie from another video game that I've played in the past and you weren't too much of an annoyance.
But okay Ellie, I'll give you the benefit of the doubt, Ellie. You can try your best at this, Ellie. Do what you can do, Ellie.
Alright, so now that that's done we're gonna dig that one too.
*mumbles* Do a big dig on that one.
*mumbles* Get that out of there.
And build that. *Mark says gibberish* And then we'll have water flowing in and then we should be -
Woo! We should be pretty GOOD!
I'm hoping anyway.
Yeah, breathe in that delicious *scoffs* contaminated oxygen.
Some of them might get a disease from all this, but hopefully it won't be too bad.
I mean we will eventually have some sort of medication, I just don't know when.
Ah, I've gotta build more beds, I forgot about that.
No power? Oh I forgot that they haven't built new batteries yet.
My refrigerator needs power please! It's very hot apparently... What? Why is the refrigerator 126 (Celsius) degrees?
Well fuck dude, that's- that's pretty hot. That's pretty hot, bruh. It's too hot for my blood. Too hot for this poor bristle blossom.
It doesn't have power yet, but as soon as that connects there it will have power and then we will need to make...
We will definitely need to make these extra batteries here...
and then probably some more power generators just to be able to make SURE that the batteries are operating 100%.
Eh, I'm gonna build...
I'm gonna build two more of those and one more of these just because I don't want to risk ANYTHING getting in the way of that.
'Cause we're about to draw just oodles of power.
So, how we doing? We've got good food, the oxygen is flowing freely, we've got harvests for us,
the algae is good... We might actually be close to out of algae, which means we'll have to dig this shit out.
I don't like being close to out of algae, cause that's death.
But we'll see. We'll see what happens.
We'll see what happens. I'm not saying we're close to death, but I'm saying being out of algae would be close to death.
Ooh shit! Oooh OOh no! Come on now! Okay, good. Alright, so I goofed there.
The plumbing has been down for a while 'cause I'm dumb.
Alright, so this has got a priority of 6, not 9.
Alright, so hopefully that'll do just fine. I'm actually gonna- just in case, I'm gonna drop these bad boys down to 6 as well.
I'm gonna make these top priority. These ones to block off to make sure no gas leaks in through there, then we should be okay.
Oh Ruby are you trapped? Wa-ah-ah-ah! okay you're fine. You're good.
Alright, so then filtration medium is gonna get there. That should be all set up. That's good to go. That makes sense to me. This will be done soon-ish as soon as they figure out the rest of this shit.
Oxygen is still a little lower than it should be, but I don't want to waste too much algae.
I'm gonna let them just carry on for a little bit because I don't want to get in their way of what they need to do 'cause I know that they need to do some things.
I'm just gonna put this at a 6 as well just so they eventually get to these things here...
Okay and WOAH it's working. It is! It's working! Ahahaha! Hahahahaha! Hahahahaha! Hahahahaha! Hahahaha!
This contaminated stuff from the shower and lavatory are flowing out there, this is flowing in here, we're good, everything is happy. I'm happy, we're happy. Everything is good.
I think everything is good. If everything is not good, then I'm going to be very upset, but I think everything is good.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm fairly certain. So, if everything IS good,
then we shouldn't have any further trouble for the immediate future.
We've got tons of Meallice, we've got lots of food, we're doing a little low on oxygen, Ruby is a little stressed, and Natalie
probably 'cause they were working in the muck a little bit. But we've got a lot of water flowing through, and this is not bad.
This is pretty good, actually. This is -  I'm not gonna lie, I had some doubts. I had some big ol' doubts.
But, I think this is... this might actually work out for me. This might actually work!
And then I go over there for the slime production
I'd let the percolators drop the slime down into there...
They'll dig through there...
The research just completed for advanced filtration for air scrubber, gas filter, and liquid filter.
That's good (x7)
Okay, so I'm gonna go for interior decor, just because, "Hey, why not?"
Give 'em something easy that can drop some stress so we make sure everybody's stress is just a little bit down
Oh yeah that son of a bitch is just gonna be pumping all day long...
We are gonna need *Stutter* Eventually we're gonna need more batteries and we're gonna need more people pumping uh...
For energy because...
Uh... *Stutter* Like they do need to be there...
I mean this, this filter is gonna take a lot of power over time.
It definitely is.
So we always gotta make sure that we got that under control.
But, SO FAR...
Yeah I'm actually gonna cancel all of this because...
W-We don't need that right now. I mean for the slime collection yeah, I'll do it for the slime collection itself but for -
Everything else...?
It's not bad.
This is- This is pretty good!
I like it! I like it, it- it's goin wel-
I'm just trying to look at it and be like,
"How can everything go horribly WRONG for me?" *Chuckle*
"HOW is this terrible?"
"In WHAT WAY am I going to DIE?"
So I'm-I'm making this a Gas Permeable one
OOOO! Hello new-comer! How you doin'?
OOOOO!
Dimentionally Inept, Can't build...
That's a problem.
Ok, Slow learner?
Naturally Robust? I'll take that!
I'll take that!
Little destructive but you know...
Better than the other ones I guess...
Alright come on in!
What's your name?
Bae?
Your Bae?
Oh Bae!
Okay Bae! Alright then Bae...
You silly billy!
Alright Bae, your gonna do me..
A lot of good.
I know you will.
Gonna be a great help at everything that we do here.
Ok so that's got storage compactors...
So what I'm about to do, is that I'm about to tunnel through a whole bunch of slime...
Which means that I'm gonna have to store the slime, but that's okay!
Cause that's what we're here for...
They're gonna be - there's gonna be a bit of stress when they - when they do this, I know.
Its a bit if a dangerous gamble to go here and just kind of...
You know, work till they drop style - do this - But it's gonna be worth it. I know it is.
We're actually gonna have multiple layers of, you know. Of this, of the percolators going.
So, we're just gonna have oodles and oodles and oodles of it.
and you - Ooooh, there you are! My cash cows. You're gonna be doing me so much good.
I'll just start with this one because I don't wanna go overboard. Because obviously my power generation isn't gonna be nearly enough to...
Compensate for all of that stuff, but we'll get there when we get there.
Like I've been saying this whole time, we'll get there when we get there. But at least this plan is coming together.
Because now, I've got this guy who's happily making slime again - which is awfully nice.
And, um, eventually we'll cut through to this guy
OH! There's three of 'em! Did I notice there was three of them before?
But there's three of them, which is even better! Because then we'll make all the slime we could possibly want.
So we should have tons and tons and tons and tons of slime.
So now I'm gonna prioritize - ooh, we got some stressed guys.
Ruby is real stressed, but not quite that bad yet.
Getting there, but not quite there yet. *mumbles*
Alright, making lost of liquid conduits.
So, everything else is going pretty ok, except we're complete out of power and that's not good because we're not producing oxygen.
Oooh. Is that how it is?
Oh we got - when did we get more algae? We got 984. That just went up all of a sudden.
I don't know. I'm not complaining though!
If we just suddenly just spawned more algae that will be better than what happened in the last episode!
- Last game session that we had.
Alright, so those are almost just about done, very close to the end of doneness!
Just about there! Almost doneness.
Oooh, so close to being done! So close.
C'mon! Just a little more!
What are they doing? Oh, no power, that's what they're doin'.
Last one! Last one!
BUUH
OK, good good good! Ok now do your thing! Do your thing gang. Do your thing.
You don't need to worry about all that. You do your thing.
You relax! Relax. RUBY! Calm down! RUBY! JESUS! RUBY!
RUBY!
*softly* Just calm down ok? It's gonna be alright.
Everything's fine.
Oh! New guy! Alright. Fine then...
We need to watch out 'cuz we're starting to use a lot more oxygen than we were before.
Nope! We don't want that!
Ok, so they're going to be dimensionally inept. I guess they could do other stuff...
Eh, Mozzarella. Oh no!
I just remembered Mozzarella from the last one....
Naaaaaw. Ok.
Alrighty then Mozzarella, you come on... Come on down.
Oh you're so sweet.
How are you guys doing? Oh, you're collecting slime.
Ok, well that's - I'm gonna put that as like a five priority.
Because we don't need to many people rushing out there until later.
But what we do need... Yeah, we are starting to use a lot more oxygen than we were.
I mean we definitely need to get the power up. That's one thing that definitely needs to happen.
We do have a lot of - I don't know why, but we have a lot of contaminated oxygen up here.
And I'm not 100% sure why... Where did that come from?
Like what's causing the contaminated oxygen build up over - is it just like something slipped by and it got up here?
Because if that is the case then it'll go away over time, but I just wanna make sure...
That it's not going to be killing anybody
I mean it's obviously not gonna kill anybody. It never did, but...
I wanna make sure that they  - it doesn't make anybody go crazy.
You know, I'm just gonna build one of these. Because there's really no harm in having another one over here.
And I don't want people breathing contaminated oxygen all day.
Ruby, you are soo stressed but...
You know you're doing great. Everybody's getting a little more stressed, and there're getting a lot more stressed than I would like.
Don't like that a lot, but we...
We'll deal with it as best we can.
That's all we can do, that's all we can do.
Who stress vomited? Oh, did Ruby do it the run away from her responsibilities? Is that what Ruby did?
Ok, we did it. Ok, so we got that research done now.
That will be a little bit better - oh that's not good...
But we have that made, so now we can make a coal generator.
And that's going to be able to provide us with just a bit more - It will produce a lot of carbon-dioxide down here, but over here, once again, not that big a deal.
Ok, two for now, two for now!
We'll see how that goes, we do have a lot of coal. But you know, I just -
I think two - one is pretty much equivalent to maybe two of the wheels, I have no idea.
Either way, it should probably produce more power, and I just wanna make sure we're good on all our power.
But it seems like these guys have actually been running so much there're almost full.
Holy shit. Well done if you did.
Aah, good stress reliever Gabriel. Doing good. Ruby still needs a lot of help.
Ruby, what does Ruby do? Ruby, are you over here Ruby? I didn't even see you over here. I don even know where you went Ruby.
Where'd you go?
I'm still worried about our oxygen situation because it's getting a little lower than I would ever want.
Oh! Good! More people! Ok, little hesitant to get another person in here just yet.
*reading* Narcoleptic... Night Owl...
I'll take that!
I'll take that. I'll take that. Yeah, that'll be good.
Heellooo Grub!
Oh your name - your name's not Grub. Oh no, your name IS Grub!
Holy crap your name is Grub! I didn't even check that.
I'm sorry I didn't pay attention to that Grub.
Hello Nails, Bae, Ellie, Neil.
Alright! You guys are wonderful! Love you lots!
Ok, those are going pretty well.
They are producing a lot of carbon-dioxide, but that's going to fall down....
And then hopefully everything will be ok.
Alright! So that's gonna solve our power problems!
I'm hoping that those things will stop - no I bet they won't stop
Oh yeah, there're not going to stop are they?
So I need to get more batteries to be able to take advantage of those coal generators.
So we got to get like a whole, huge bank of 'em.
Just so we know...
Lashing out? Who's lashing out!?
Who the heck is soo stressed that they're lashing out? Who did that?
What? Goddammit! Of course! They go for the same thing they always do.
The one thing they need to survive! Jesus. Just stupid idiots...
Ok, so stress is going down a bit. Stress is going down.
We've got these big ol' batteries there that are gonna be...
Banking all this extra power from that.
Sooo, we're doing pretty ok.... I think.
Yeah, we're doing pretty ok.
So we got all those, which means that we should be able to continue these.
We can enable these now.
And then lets try to mop up all this shit. Mop it up.
And then we should be good.
So things should be... Rolling a bit better now.
We're getting a good amount of algae.
We had a good amount of algae.
But we've got a good amount of slime, and then as we continue on with those percolators we'll be able to create more and more algae,
from the infinite supply of slime that this Puft is going to be consuming,
and emitting lots and lots of that shit.
So that's good.
And then, I'm going to make another shower.
For these lovely people.
So that they don't have to sufferrrrr...
At the hands of bullshit.
Ok, nitey-nite time. You guys go to bedy-by. You guys go to bedy-by!
You guys go to bedy-by!
Ok, so I think we are doing pretty well.
This is a good launching point. It seems to be relatively balanced.
I've got power.
I've got food.
I could always make more food -
- overheated? Really?
It's overheated? There? Probably because I've got all these electronics over here that I don't necessarily need.
I might have to move those around.
Um, it's nice and cool down here, but there's no oxygen.
I'll see about fixing that in the next episode.
*mumbling* I'll have to see if it cools down, whatever, its fine.
It fluctuates a bit and its not the worst thing in the world.
But we will see about getting this all sorted -
- Unreachable? Is it unreachable?
What if you dig here?
So, those are gonna - those are gonna suck the contaminated air out that should work out pretty well.
We got a newcomer. I don't know if I want a newcomer.
I'll leave that for another episode. I think we're in a good stopping point right now. Plenty of food - all this other stuff.
They're finally free to do that shit which I assigned them to do that AGES ago.
But this seems to be ok.
We will get filtration medium for that one very soon.
Uuuh, yeah. Should be ok.
We still got some stressed people, and I don't like that at all.
I think I'm going to have to...
Lashing out? Aw shit. Where?
Where you lashing out?
Oh of course Eugine. Good job. Ok.
But that's fine because what I'm gonna do next is...
I'm going to build a mess...
So that they can at least have a nice place to eat.
Aw, someone is lashing out. The stress is pretty high!
I wish it wasn't. I wish it wasn't.
I'm not 100% sure why it is so high but,
I guess it can't be helped for now. So I'm going to pause this right here.
We're at the cusp of controlling this because once it starts to get big,
it starts to get harder, and harder to control.
The oxygen is getting a little lower,
We're running a little bit out of algae.
Like the percolators aren't producing as much algae as I would like, but
the concept of the water filters and purifiers are solid.
So long as those are running, we'll have enough water to, say, make into oxygen directly. Which would be nice.
But we shall see...
So thank you everybody so much for watching! I hope you've been enjoying this thus far
I will get back to this game in the future. I think I've played it out for today.
But I hope you guys enjoyed it a lot. Because I am in love with this game.
And again, it's only in pre-alpha. So thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always, I will se you, in the next video! BYE-BYE